nobody knows how to throw a party like
you gronk but i want you to tell me
about this party like a player event
that you're throwing inside your crib
you're offering up the crib
so the people can come to your house and
party like a player and hang out at your
house explain that to me yes i'm a good
guy like that you know what i mean just
always want everyone to have a good time
you know the fans out there to have a
good time gronk definitely knows how to
celebrate so we teamed up with him and
groupon to get all the deets on their
party like a player contest where you
can party at gronk's actual house i'm
handing my keys over to groupons to
throw the ultimate big game uh watch
party there's going to be one lucky
winner and they're going to be able to
bring up the 15 friends and groupons you
know providing mini golf balls houses
and two of my brothers are going to be
there and they love this wow so it's
going to be a wild night in your house
that's why i did it with groupon because
they're the experience pros for contest
rules and to sign up visit the groupon
website or use their app through
february 2nd be nutty